thank thank you for coming guys my name
is Kevin herder and I have an
announcement I'd like to make from here
on out I'd like to be referred as red
velvet
[Music]
[Music]
all right so when you say red-velvet do
you mean rebel it like the cake or like
the fabric you know we're in the
practice study one day you know with
this whole array of cupcakes out on out
on the table and you see that right
there
smooth and I just thought of my jump
shot so that was where I was smooth all
right be honest with us did you did you
give yourself that nickname what did it
move yeah I didn't you know you know
once I saw it I was you know I was with
it I was I was there with it but now it
was it was not me or a fake burner count
of me that started the trend of tweeting
out red velvet it kind of just started
to catch fire
yeah I noticed it one day scrolling
through my timeline and yeah I think I
know where people find the red from and
then the velvet part everything else
that goes with it you I'd like to think
was a compliment you know seeing the way
you Lunas of my game and other and there
as so I think just the two and two
together is just fine art so is this
gonna be like Metta World Peace are you
changing your government name should we
expect to see red velvet on the back of
your Hawks Jersey I'm still waiting to
see fan approval you know from this
announcement how that kind of takes fire
you I can't answer that for sure at this
time but you know we're just going to
run with it see where it goes all right
guys is just like to thank you again for
coming out here and if anyone would like
some samples to you know I got shouldn't
more here if anyone wants I'm gonna
leave them up here in the podium